Sí la verdad es que estas ciudades son
ciudades que resiste que ha resistido la
gente de aquí es muy orgullosa de ser de
esta ciudad y lo ha demostrado en todos
estos meses pero a diferencia de lo que
vimos en el 2014 cuando la guerra en el
este era más circunscrita Ahora se ve
mucho más el cansancio el agotamiento
la falta de Esperanza de las personas en
que este conflicto acabe sobre todo los
jóvenes los jóvenes que han vivido ya
años de pandemia que ahora se tuvieron
que enfrentar a un año de guerra y que
por tanto ven como su futuro sea de
alguna forma congelado y puede no pueden
continuar con su desarrollo con sus
estudios con su ingreso en el mundo
laboral de una forma normal como en
otras partes del mundo
Esta es la el humor un poco en esta
ciudad se ve cierta normalidad por
supuesto la gente de alguna forma
también nos ha dicho que se ha
acostumbrado a la guerra por tanto hoy
durante la han sonado las sirenas en
varias ocasiones las personas no se
inmutan ya no no no no manifiestan
sentimientos de miedo
por estos sonidos que que continúan
escuchándose aquí en Jacob en pero este
la realidad es que los ánimos no son muy
altos Lamentablemente